impfung für ein stückchen freiheit vor
etwas mehr als einer woche bekam bild
reporterin sara frenkel in israel ihre
zweite chor ohne impfung und zwar mitten
in der bild gleich sendung nun soll für
sie das normale leben in dem land wieder
möglich sein
über die hälfte der bevölkerung also
rund vier millionen menschen wurden
bereits zum zweiten mal geimpft
ich bin auch eine der von den
glücklichen und habe seit gestern meinen
grünen im passt damit komme ich jetzt
wieder in restaurants café ist ins
sportstudio museen ich möchte heute
einmal testen ob das wirklich stimmt und
wie streng kontrolliert wird
in israel herrscht im letzten jahr einer
der strengsten lockte und der welt und
nun ist das land vorreiter in sachen
info die zahl der infizierten sinkt und
die regierung lockert immer mehr
maßnahmen eine woche nach der zweiten
spritze bekommt jeder den grünen pass
und damit immer mehr freiheiten
tatsächlich habe ich mit meinem grünen
pass bekommen
ich musste ihn sowohl an der tür zeigen
als auch am tisch hat er kenne mich auch
nochmal gefragt ob ich denn schon meine
zwei impfungen bekommen haben und den
grünen passen mit mir trage andere
menschen die diese nun passt nicht
hatten die müssen leider weiterhin
draußen sitzen oder wieder nach hause
gehen denn abstands und hygiene regeln
gelten auch weiterhin aber verdienen
dürfen gastronomen im inneren nur eine
beschränkte anzahl an menschen bewerten
so bin ich sicher die mitarbeiter sind
sicher und auch die gäste es ist also
schon in ordnung
sogar der besuch in einem spa ist für
die geimpften wieder möglich der einlass
wird wie immer streng kontrolliert ich
habe dieses wochenende geburtstag und
nach all der zeit verdienen wie eine
kleine auszeit
in israel finden bald sogar erste
konzerte statt die tickets waren
innerhalb von minuten ausverkauft das
leben normalisiert sich
ich habe das heute mal getestet in
jerusalem und es wird auch recht streng
kontrolliert was auf jeden fall gut ist
im hinblick darauf dass man natürlich
auch möchte dass das virus nicht wieder
ausbricht
mehr nachrichten breaking news nur bei
bild schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren